are we looking at a cabinet position
what's going on here
uh so that's there's absolutely nothing
has been
you know uh discussed in like a
hyper-official
level but unofficially um in the
conversations we've had people like we'd
love to have you on the team and
work with you like things like that i
love you
what do you want to be what's your dream
what's your dream position there
so what i've been saying uh to
folks is that i want to try and speed us
up on these technology issues and and
we can you know i think the three of us
could talk about this stuff for hours
but our government is just so out to
launch on technology issues
and so that could be ai
that could be the selling and reselling
of our data
that could be uh media and social media
that could be
mental health issues that are attendant
with smartphone adoption on the part of
teenage girls
they're all of these issues does that
cabinet position even exist
it does not all right and there's
there's a part
but there there's an advantage there
because uh
if they created a new role for me then
it's not like they'd be blocking anyone
out because it's not like there are like
15 people being like hey i really want
to be can we create
innovation and technology can we create
a new cabinet
branch yes that is something so
yeah you can that's the short answer i
mean that seems like a great
a great place to go and perfect gang
style cabinet of technology
um secretary of technology secretary of
technology and innovation
actually the washington post just just
put that out there today they said
here's the cabinet we recommend
and they said andrew yang like a
secretary of technology innovation that
advises
all of the other uh cabinet members
that's so
cool that would be amazing i'm lobbying
for that from now on
can we do anything i actually think joe
would i think joe could garner a lot of
of uh support by by making that happen
do we have any input in making that
happen like can we do anything
well if people were to if there was a
groundswell of support being like hey
joe
like if you signal to everyone that
you're going to name andrew the
secretary of technology and innovation
it would help us vote for you
um they might do it because there's no
reason not to really i mean
like again it's not like a role that
exists presently and so you know it
would make him seem forward thinking so
if
enough people and this stuff you know
it's not
uh that under the radar in the sense
again the washington post just
recommended it yeah so and when i've
spoken to people that like me
they were like well this like makes me
more excited about joe if yeah
bring you on this capacity yeah totally
if you get this cabinet position
which we're all hoping for tell me tell
me what are those
first things that you think like you're
sitting down in america you're part of
the president's cabinet what do we need
to do first what is the most pressing
things we need to address
in this country america i mean
clearly it's cash relief and universal
basic income you know it's like that's
like the simple thing
um it sounds you know that's to me the
single
best thing we could do for people so
let's say if you say something
technology related then i i
you know i i'd actually choose something
related
which is what we talked about earlier
around the fact that we didn't actually
have a system set up to get people money
so we use the irs check distribution
system
um and i think it's bad for our
confidence in our government
that it sucks so bad at a lot of these
things
where like if you go to uh
your bank's website or whatever you just
expect it to work
generally at a certain level um and then
so you'd be like well
why did the government have something so
one thing i'd love to invest in would be
essentially a citizen portal
where if there was something like we're
trying to get you money or trying to get
you information
or so the lamest version of this would
be a citizen portal where
it's essentially like here are all of
these links to other [ __ ] government
websites that you can go to like that
would be the
the absolute worst version the best
version would be so
you know i mean like one of those boards
where it's like here's a
freaking flurry of websites to go to
[ __ ] you but no
but but like like the good version
would be like a slick interface where
you know like the information from let's
call it your tax returns
uh or uh from
the passport office or wherever the heck
like could actually be compiled
because part of the thing that makes me
angry right now is that
like you're hearing a lot of messages
from folks all the time
associated with politics which is like
trust us trust us you gotta trust us and
it's like well
like you guys don't really deliver the
same level
as like some of the other organizations
i'm used to interacting with
um so i would love to try and help the
government deliver at like uh
on a technical level because i think it
would be enormous for our confidence
so that would be something i would love
especially if it was tied to universal
basic income because i think that there
is a relationship where
um we need to actually know who you are
know how to get you money have to have
some kind of secure
relationship with you and interface with
you if we're going to try and
you know add value don't you think the
big
problem is that all of our elected
officials and even you know
uh joe bide i mean how old is joe he's
like 74 or something like that i mean
um i think i think he's uh like 76 or 77
i think
um i i don't want to misspeak i should
know that he's
he's in israel yeah okay are you looking
it up yeah okay let's see
i mean maybe when your team can yeah
look it up uh zach
he's uh 77 years old whoa
so don't you think that's the we need
young people who
understand this like a 70s i have no 77
year old people they're not
interested in cash app do you know what
i mean
they understand checks and that's not
their fault
it's just the way it is but i think
like we have this tendency of electing
especially lately old people to office
even donald trump is in his 70s right
he's like 72 73 years old
i mean these although he's a little 74
to be oh 74. check that one somehow he
doesn't
somehow trump i guess he's got a young
he's got a young energy right yeah such
an [ __ ] he's got that [ __ ] energy
that yeah
he does a lot i think he does a lot with
this he does like a spray tan and then
he's used to the cameras i think he just
on camera i think he comes off like that
obviously i never met him in person but
i have a feeling if you saw him in
person he would look that age
do you i do give him credit he's he has
a more youthful
spirit for whatever reason and he's on
twitter that's pretty that's pretty epic
but that being said i don't think trump
uses cash app either
and so what we need is peop is younger
people i really truly think we just need
younger people and that's one of the
reasons
not that was one of the reasons why i
liked you right and one of the reasons i
like aoc is that
we just like aoc does instagram live
every like super frequently to talk
directly with her
uh yeah she's interested she's like a
digital native
uh i think the average age of a member
of congress is 62
to your point ethan so it's not as
presidential candidates right someone
called it a gerontocracy like a rule by
the old
we essentially have a gerundocracy in
the united states of america
for a number of reasons uh one of the
main reasons
is that after you get into washington
you should try and stay there forever
and it's actually very hard to defeat
and incumbent so you have folks
like um nancy pelosi i believe is uh
around joe's age
um and she feels great but she does
but our leaders are of another
generation
uh because of the way the structure this
is
the the structures are set up and
it's one reason why i'm four term limits
um where
you should go to dc as a term of service
get something done and then get out uh
and it would help keep our legislators
more
current and fresh and modern to your
point ethan because
if you go to dc you'll find it is not
exactly a tech friendly town
uh you know let you go i'll tell the
story that was gonna make you angry but
it'll be totally consistent
with your understanding of the world so
uh so i was on the trail and then there
was like this uh
uh asian kid he's like
you know mid-20s maybe um and he
interned at his congressional office
and then they asked him to like uh do
do something um uh
like answering messages or data related
like in the office
and he was smart so he set up like a
program to like automate the process
and make it so that okay like this thing
will like happen more seamlessly and
like
you know like less labor um this will be
great
and then they yelled at him for it and
said like no we didn't want you to do
that
like like where we actually
preferred the way that like the other
person uh
could just understand and just like sit
there and like just peck at it
um all the time he was like what the
hell is going on there's like a
congressional office and so he left
he now works at facebook he like went
and worked in dc for like a summer was
like
they are freaking stuck in like the
stone age let me get the hell out of
here and then he like peaced out to
silicon valley so like that that is the
general culture in dc where you go there
and you feel like you just
rewound uh like a number of years
and if you go into some of these
government agencies it's much much worse
because
some of them have been underfunded so
you have like very strange
patchwork technologies uh from past
years
uh you know like i mean i might be
exaggerating but probably not my much
like windows like 2005 or whatever like
you go in and they'll just be
stuff all over um in in different
uh different government organizations so
it
that so that's that's the government we
have um and like you said before it's
like not really anyone's fault
um but we need to try and speed them up
um and if i'm in position to try and
move that
in a better direction like i would take
it and do everything i could
[Music]
it sounds really we have to necessarily
we have to do that i mean
i think the i think the problem is that
the rate of technology
has cert as past our our people
it's been going so fast that it's past
them right
when joe biden was a one in his 40s
even 50s like 25
26 7 years ago it was uh we were 1995.
i mean i don't even know that
smartphones were popular then i don't
think no not even close
not even close right so i mean in in his
own experience in government
the technology has ran around him like
30 times
so yeah it's a new it's a new world they
got rid of the office of technology
assessment in 1995 the year you just
perfected the perfect time to get rid of
it
yeah they had a they had a department
that advised
members of congress on what technology
is jews you know they should care about
and like
opinions like why why did they do that
um why did they get rid of the office of
technology assessment
uh you know like it was like to quote
unquote save money which is like the
most as9 thing in the world because the
budget of the entire thing was like
25 million it was like a [ __ ] drop in
the bucket just had some smart people
around telling you it's like hey
so you know where the legislators get
their technology guidance from now
the technology companies the technology
companies are like do
absolutely nothing because everything is
perfect
and then the legislators are like yeah
that sounds about right so
they're like perfect that yeah whatever
requires the least of me
yeah so and especially if you're
donating 25 million
to my campaign that's fantastic there
was a period and it's been interesting
to see the
pendulum swing somewhat so the silicon
valley could do no wrong for a long time
where dc is discriminators like oh
you're like the innovators you're the
super value creators and you're rich as
[ __ ] and you donate to my campaign so
let's just like
like leave you the heck alone and just
sing your praises every chance we get
uh and then that pendulum has swung
because of
uh like uh facebook screwing some things
up and
uh and some other problems uh so now
everyone's starting to turn on a turn
towards them and be like wait a minute
like you know is this really been like
cool that amazon
is you know like uh andrew yang future
secretary of technology and innovation
love this potentially and if that
happened i certainly have you two
and a lot of other people to thank but
the big thing right now is just for us
to help each other try and get through
this mess
and you know stay strong and healthy
ourselves because you can't help anyone
if you can't
you know like uh help yourself but then
if you do have the capacity to help
others please do lend someone a hand
because like someone in your life needs
a hand
can we count on an interview from
washington dc
a year from now yeah i mean definitely
like if i'm the secretary
of technology and innovation uh
then we'll have so much to talk about
and yeah i agree
i'll even end up being like these types
of being like hey send me
ideas citizens because i am now your
and andrew if there are ufos will you
tell us
but you have asked if i find out there
are ufos uh
i will tell people because we all know
they're there already okay andrew let me
ask you this
if someone's like okay andrew we're
gonna give we're gonna tell you the ufos
and the aliens and all this crazy [ __ ]
exists
but you can't tell anyone do you tell us
[Laughter]
depends on who it is really i mean you
know if it's someone i can be like sorry
man
like i just had to tell people that it'd
be good people always say that but
there's no way you would actually be
able to tell us
don't you see the problem i i do see the
problem if they bring me into the circle
of
ufo trust then it's hard to run outside
of the circle
and tell ethan and hila just before you
die
just get the blanket yeah blink twice on
your on your deathbed
um that done deal deathbed ufo
confession
all right thank you for listening in i
hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]